WILDFIRES IN WESTERN TURKEY
HAVE BREACHED A THERMAL POWER
PLANT IN WOOL A.
CREWS WERE ABLE TO REMOVE
EXPLOSIVE MATERIALS BEFORE HAND,
BUT THERE ARE FEARS THAT THE
TONS OF COAL LEFT INSIDE COULD
STILL IGNITES.
AND IN GREECE, MORE THAN 70
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN HOSPITALIZED
WITH BREATHING PROBLEMS AFTER
WILDFIRES BROKE OUT AN AND
AROUND ATHENS, ENVELOPING THE
CITY IN A SMOKY HAZE.
CNN'S KIM RUPERT REPORTS ON THE
EXTREME CONDITIONS IN EUROPE.
>> WHAT BEGAN AS A CLEAR BLUE
SKY OVER THE AGGRESSION CAPITAL
TUESDAY SOON TURNED INTO PLUMES
OF SMOKE SMOTHERED BY ATHENS.
BY THURSDAY, WAS A THICK SMOG
SMOTHERS THE.
CITY RAGING FIRES RAGING IN THE
OUTSKIRTS OF ATHENS FORCED
PEOPLE TO FLEE FROM THEIR
HOMES.
THE FIRES ARE LARGELY
CONTROLLED, BUT THEY COULD
SURGE AGAIN AS GREECE BATTLES
ITS WORST HEAT WAVE IN MORE
THAN 30 YEARS.
IN NEIGHBORING TURKEY,
FIREFIGHTERS ARE STRUGGLING TO
CONTAIN DEADLY BLAZES SWEEPING
ACROSS PARTS OF THE COUNTRY,
BECOMING MORE DANGEROUS BY THE
MOMENT.
AFTER INCINERATING SWATHS OF
FOREST, FLAMES HAVE REACHED A
POWER STATION THE COUNTRY
SOUTHWEST, THE PLANT WAS
EVACUATED AND SOME OF ITS
INFLAMMABLE MATERIAL WAS DUMPED,
BUT ENVIRONMENTALISTS ARE STILL
WORRIED.
THE PRESIDENT OF TURKEY SAYS
THAT THIS IS THE WORST FIRE
THAT THE COUNTRY HAS EVER SEEN.
HEAVY GUSTS OF WIND WITH
THREATEN THE ONE COUNTRY TO
CONTINUE BURNING.
SURROUNDING COUNTRIES ALSO FACE
HEAT WARNINGS.
WE USE SCIENTISTS SAY THAT THE
MEDITERRANEAN IS BECOMING A
FIRE HOT SPOT, WITH CRISIS IS A
THREAT TO ALL IN EUROPE.
KIM GRAVEL, AT CNN, ATHENS.
>> SO LET'S GO TO ATHENS WHERE
A LINDA POOH-POOH LOW IS
STANDING BY.
SO WHY CAN WE DO TO CONTAIN
THESE FIRES?
>> AT THE MOMENT, THERE ARE A
LOT OF FIRES STILL BURNING.
SOME OF THEM VERY SERIOUS.
THERE IS A FIRE ON THE ISLAND
OF A VIA THAT SEEMS TO BE OUT
OF CONTROL AT THE MOMENT, AND
MORE VILLAGES ARE BEING
EVACUATED.
THIS IS A TOURIST DESTINATION
AS WELL SO WELL AND THERE'S
ALSO A VERY LARGE FIRE WALL
BURNING AROUND ANCIENT OLYMPIA.
SO THERE IS LARGE EFFORTS TO
CONTAIN THE FIRE BEFORE IT
REACHES THE ARCHEOLOGICAL
SPACE.
SO JUST TO GIVE YOU AN IDEA OF
THE SCALE OF THE FIRES IN
GREECE IN THE LAST 48 HOURS,
WE'VE SEEN A GOOD 2 HATRED
FIRES WILL BREAK OUT AS A
RESULT OF THE HEAT WAVE.
THE TEMPERATURES HERE ARE
SWELTERING, WE'RE LOOKING AT AN
AVERAGE TEMPERATURE OF 43
DEGREES CELSIUS A DAY.
THAT IS THE HIGHEST, AND THE
MOST EXTENSIVE HEAT WAVE WE'VE
HAD IN GREECE IN OVER 4
DECADES.
AND ATHENS, THINKS --
CONDITIONS REMAIN DIFFICULT.
THERE WAS A LARGE FIRE THAT HAS
NOW BEEN PUT OUT, BUT IT WAS
BURNING FOR A COUPLE OF DAYS
HERE UNTIL YESTERDAY.
AND AS A RESULT, THE SKIES
REMAIN HAZY, IT'S DIFFICULT TO
BREATHE, YOU CAN REALLY TASTE,
ALMOST, THE TASTES SMOKE.
AND AUTHORITIES HAVE BEEN
ASKING PEOPLE TO STAY INDOORS
AND TRIED TO KEEP THEIR WINDOWS
CLOSED IN ORDER TO KEEP THE AIR
PARTICLES OUT FROM REACHING
THEIR HOMES.
SO THIS IS A HEAT WAVE THAT WE
EXPECT TO LAST FOR A WEEK.
WE EXPECT CONDITIONS TO REMAIN
DIFFICULT AND THERE IS ALSO
WEATHER FORECASTS THAT WINDS
ARE LIKELY TO PICK UP,
ROSEMARY.
>> AND AS WE TALKED ABOUT LAST
HOUR, A LOT OF PEOPLE THERE IN
GREECE DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO AIR
CONDITIONING.
WHAT ABOUT EFFORTS TO SHELTERS
SOME OF THESE PEOPLE WHO COULD
PERHAPS LOSE THEIR HOMES, OR
CERTAINLY AND YOUR VERY SEVERE
CONDITIONS?
>> A LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE ALREADY
LOST THEIR HOMES ON THE ISLAND,
AT LEAST 150 HOMES HAVE BEEN
DESTROYED.
AND DURING THE LARGE ATHENS
FIRE, DOZENS OF HOUSES AS WELL.
SO AUTHORITIES HAVE TAKEN
MEASURES, THEY ARE HAVE ENSURED
THAT THESE PEOPLE ARE BEING PUT
UP IN HOTELS.
AND THERE ARE SHELTERS, THERE
ARE COMMUNAL SPACES FOR PEOPLE
WHO DON'T HAVE AIR CONDITIONING,
WH